[Music]
joining me now is republican congressman
jim banks and manhattan institute senior
fellow chris ruffo uh congressman
speaking of winds of change in
washington
you are beginning to take aim are you
not possibly at disney's copyrights
explain
uh yes laura this is uh probably a long
time coming at the end of the day we
take our kids to disney world for family
vacation not indoctrination
and disney as for a long time they've
attacked american values i've never seen
them attack a chinese law but here they
are attacking a very popular
law in florida that most floridians
support most americans support and if
they're going to attack the the american
laws that are being put in place by duly
elected governors and representatives at
the state level then they don't they
don't they don't deserve all the special
american laws and protections that are
granted to their company so i wrote
disney a letter today and i said when
your copyright laws expire which is
coming up in the next few years and they
come back to congress and spend millions
and millions of dollars to lobby members
of congress like myself i'm not going to
vote for it i'm not going to vote for
special laws that help disney when
disney is attacking american values on a
regular basis like what they are in this
situation with this situation in florida
specifically and in a lot of other ways
as well i mean i think they just take it
for granted that they're going to have
their copyrights extended
forever
i mean we you know i think of the
book like a christmas carol like that's
in the public domain now that's not you
don't you know dickens is gone we don't
we don't continue that in any type of
trademark or copyright and
i think congress has to start examining
this across the board for a lot of
companies chris you're looking at a
whole bunch of issues uh involving
disney including an issue regarding
child predators uh and specifically
about um
lobbying to oppose increasing protocols
for sexual abuse on cruise ships
tell us about this
yeah that's right i spent the day
pouring through criminal arrest records
and court records and while disney is
now presenting itself as the moral
arbiter about children and sexuality
there is a dark side to disney in fact
over the last few years dozens and
dozens of disney employees have been
arrested for child pornography child sex
exploitation and even child rape
but more concerning than that which is
already in a huge
moral scandal
disney executives through their trade
union lobbyist associations uh actually
pushed to reduce the most stringent
regulations and reporting requirements
for sexual abuse on the cruise ships uh
there was even one story reported a
number of years ago where disney did a
cover-up
for a man who was an employee of that
cruise ship who molested 11 year an 11
year old girl disney refused to report
it allowed him to evade authorities and
flee back to the country of india so i'm
not going to sit here for one minute and
take moral lectures from these moral
midgets like the disney ceo and the
disney president who have been covering
for hiring and even enabling child sex
predators for decades
well at this point congressman it would
seem to me that parents
they had a choice in virginia and they
chose to go with glenn younkin because
of the schools issue in part and there
are a lot of other issues biden's wildly
unpopular so you've got to wonder why
the democrats
are deciding to go down this road now
i said this is a hill they're willing to
die on apparently i mean the country is
not with them on these issues certainly
not regarding children
and this bill is so it's such common
sense and it's so needed not just in
florida but every country every state in
the country laura i mean you look at
what this bill does i by the way i have
an eight-year-old daughter i don't want
her indoctrinated about sexual behavior
at school or at disney world and so you
do have to wonder why why are the
democrats so hell-bent on opposing
legislation and laws like this that the
vast majority of the american people
support but you have these these woke
executives at places like disney who by
the way as i said earlier they've never
protested anything in ch about about
china they completely turn a blind eye
and support uighur muslim genocide in
china but they want to attack governor
desantis and the good people of florida
for passing a law that the vast majority
of people in that state elected their
representatives to pass to begin with so
it's an attack on american democracy we
shouldn't reward him for it if they want
to act like a political action committee
they should be treated like a political
action committee i mean frankly if
that's what the whole brand is going to
become i know they give a lot of
donations to republicans and democrats
which is fine but if they're going to
actively advocate day after day on this
one particular issue then they're just
going to have to see where the chips
fall on this but chris here's how the
rest of the media is reacting to this
controversy
you may be talking about a problem that
doesn't exist
it's just like critical race theory what
they want to do is keep yelling about it
to get people in their homes questioning
what conversations are happening around
sex that don't actually exist i think
the problem for the republican party is
that it it goes to what democrats can
use and frankly independents as well to
continue to paint the party as
intolerant as bigoted
well chris it's moved from tolerance to
you must accept and advocate this for
children in some school settings in this
country
yeah we we do this very weird slippery
slippery slope with the left where they
say something doesn't exist and then you
blink and they say it's mandatory but
they're playing this same failed
playbook that they tried with critical
race theory uh we
educated 175 million americans about
critical race during the last 18 months
uh they're with us by a two to one
margin we're seeing those same numbers
for the parental bill of rights so
really this is a combination of
projection and denial uh it's going to
lead the left to melt down they don't
know how to get out from behind these
activists they're trying to take
critical race theory and gender ideology
to its logical extension which is really
chaos uh devastation uh and confusion
for kids um most american people will
not stand for it most american people
are standing up against it and they're
gonna find out where the american people
stand come november yeah i i beg that
they run on this issue because i'd say
one word that we don't use a lot on
television innocence
the innocence of our our little kids
is at stake now and they're innocent
little children they should be protected
by all of us frankly congressman chris
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else